when it comes to improving one's
performance on the server
it is safe to say that there is pretty
much
nothing that gamers won't at the very
least
try from peripherals and aim trainers to
loungewear and even unregulated
cognitive enhancer drugs
you will run out of money before you run
out of options to supposedly
level up your game but while you can
spend hours searching out the latest and
greatest in gamer tech
there is still one unfortunate
unavoidable reality
you must confront eventually
you're gonna have to play the game
because cheaters feeders and kids
without their monitors turned on aside
for some people sitting down at their
computer and queueing ranked isn't as
easy as clicking a button for some
the very idea of playing ranked makes
them
well
anxious it was really hard for me to
just want to like queue and like get a
loss or whatever i was really like
scared of like losing and like looking
bad then i'd lose a game of brood war
and my brain would be like you're not
worthy of love we have a lot of people
who don't have the training or the
background or the exposure to be able to
cope with the anxiety that comes with
that so today we're taking a look at
ladder anxiety that feeling of dread
when deciding whether or not to queue up
for a game or that surge of emotion
right in the middle of a game
why does it happen and are there things
you can do to either mitigate or
eliminate this feeling
[Applause]
okay so before we start talking about
ladder anxiety please be sure to check
out our brand new streaming initiatives
at twitch.tv slash the score esports
we're going to be hanging out playing
games doing watch parties and just
generally chilling so be sure to tune in
it'll be a good time i promise so when
you think about it video games have
essentially made the phenomenon of
performance anxiety something that
anyone anywhere can access instantly at
home from their desks
right away
yay
because yeah it obviously isn't
something that's just limited to video
games athletes have been struggling with
performance anxiety since like the very
beginning of
professional grass touching i just
didn't get it because
it's hard to understand something you
can't see or touch
so when i got to college and began my
career as a division one athlete i never
thought i would struggle with these
issues yet many athletes do struggle and
while these sports do take place in the
physical realm
mental fortitude can be just as
important so elite athletes coaches and
the people who surround athletes
know very well the importance of sports
psychology and they're beginning to
embrace it so that was my mental switch
it was like an actor getting ready for a
film you got to put yourself in that
cage when you're in that cage you are
that character and some players can
actually go years without any sort of
struggle before finally hitting that
wall i just remember not quite feeling
right
i mean we went through a few plays there
was a time out i got to the huddle and
that's when i just i felt something that
i had never felt before i could i
couldn't catch my breath
i felt like my mind was completely out
athletes often have a lot of lead up to
actually playing or competing during
that time they can draw on techniques to
moderate the anxiety they may feel or
engage in rituals that help them get
into the right mental space
many do exactly that whether it's a
weird pseudo-scientific medical practice
or just a good luck ritual gotta have
the high socks got it from my father you
know seeing a picture of him in a
yearbook
gotta have a headband gotta eat some
form of chicken before every game and
the night before each game i sleep in
the opposing team's game short but
queuing into a ranked match just takes
the press of a button a lot easier than
asking an nba pro for their shorts and
in a lot of games the ranked queue will
be as fast if not faster than a casual
one i'm very nervous right now we will
try and attempt to overcome
here we go i click the button where
there is no turning back all of this is
to say that while there might be a lot
of similarities there's gotta be some
differences too and some ways to help
improve your mental game that you don't
need to be a superstar athlete to
incorporate so to discuss where the
anxiety comes from and how much we can
learn from traditional sports we turned
once more to dr madison klarkowski a
professor of computer science at the
university of saskatchewan who
specializes in computer human
interaction there has actually been some
uh research examining the differences
between
sports like anxiety in a physical sports
match like in hockey or in football
versus anxiety uh in esports and
not terribly many differences emerge
it's actually a pretty similar
experience now sure compared to physical
sports there is an overall lower risk of
injury in esports and so fear of a new
injury or of aggravating an old one is
less of a factor your own self-efficacy
perception of opponents ability
and importance to match everything that
is all pretty similar between sports and
esports it's more parallels than there
are differences so we i think we can
turn pretty readily to sports research
sports science um and
kind of see if we can apply those
findings to esports on the esports side
of things we started to see a surge in
players talking openly about ranked or
latter anxiety with the massive rise of
starcraft brood war was incredibly
popular so for some players it was their
first brush with a ranked grind plus
starcraft is a deep game played mostly
online and a 1v1 rts competition leaves
you with
no one to blame but yourself frankly
it's kind of intimate you know i'm
just kind of looking forward to when she
feels ready you know
ready for what
well like you know 1v1 means zero hour
yeah i can't imagine anything more
intimate
given all that starcraft was the perfect
candidate to provoke these feelings of
anxiety in players
giving rise to the term
ladder anxiety if you followed brood war
or starcraft 2 then you probably heard
the term at some point and it was the
subject of a lot of discussion because
it was clearly something that affected a
lot of players and i actually was
someone that had ladder anxiety when i
was in starcraft so it was really hard
for me to just want to like you and like
get a loss or whatever i was really like
scared of like losing and like looking
bad um
so actually that kind of helps because i
learned how to like look at replays and
like find other methods to like get
better and to kind of like hone being on
the process of improvement but today you
don't have to play starcraft to obsess
over the decision to queue up or not for
what feels like the past decade nearly
every competitive game that has released
with multiplayer has had some species of
ranked matchmaking by having something
that is competitive with stakes that is
accessible to everyone we have a lot of
people who don't have the training or
the background or the exposure to this
format
um
to be able to cope with the anxiety that
comes with that that obsession is
fascinating though because on the one
hand you'll have a lot of players who
will simply avoid situations in which
they may be forced to not only confront
other players in a competitive
environment but their criticism you
needn't look further than the incredible
popularity of starcraft 2's vs ai mode
to see that some people would rather
just chill out and have a fun game with
a friend and hey there is nothing wrong
with that but in general are you happy
with like the amount of players that you
that you see in tremendously happy um we
had some goals in our head you know and
i've been very optimistic and those bars
were even shattered the data is showing
right now that in certain months more
people are playing co-op in multiplayer
that is unless you
like many people
have a sort of innate desire to test
your own abilities and limits or at the
very least to see yourself improve a bit
you could argue that sport and by
extension esport is all just one big
manifestation of this desire so for a
lot of people those two things conflict
you want to test yourself and see how
good you really are then you want to
improve on that but you may feel anxious
about the entire experience one term for
this anxiety is competitive state
anxiety and it can affect both your
performance in game and your willingness
to practice in the first place and
believe it or not this is something that
even the best sports and esports
competitors also grapple with well i
can't say you know definitively you know
x percentage of people um
experience competition anxiety or ranked
anxiety or ladder anxiety i can say that
it isn't unique to um players that might
have a lower skill level but that people
across all
um
skill levels all expertise can
experience it so
why does this feeling happen well
obviously there are a ton of reasons but
let's talk about the most common ones
the first thing to talk about is the
concept of self-efficacy self-efficacy
is a big one and self-efficacy is your
perception of your ability to achieve
your goals or perform at a adequate
level and if you don't have that
requisite level of self-efficacy if you
don't have that requisite belief in
yourself to perform at that level then
that is going to lead to anxiety about
competing it might seem like a rather
intuitive concept but the fact is that
for many of us we don't think explicitly
about our own self-perception and even
trying to think about it can be hampered
by other barriers like mood negative
moods such as sadness fatigue or
frustration can not only increase your
own expectations of your own performance
but will simultaneously reduce
self-efficacy so you'll expect more from
yourself well believing that you can't
actually do as much as you need to do
like your standards for yourself will
raise and you don't think you'll be able
to meet those standards even something
like others believing that you are
likely to fail can impact your own
self-efficacy look you probably have an
idea of how good of a player you are you
might even associate that idea with an
in-game rank like you might say to
someone hey i'm at least a gold player
or i would be mg if my utility was
better the thing is when you play a
ranked mode the system is designed to
put you in a game where you are playing
with and being pitted against players
of in and around the same skill level as
you
now
that is not to say
that it always succeeds
obviously people don't understand
improvement or how to learn seriously
losing in silver when it's clearly
platinum r losing in silver bro oh my
god your challenger player the goal
shouldn't be to fixate on a specific
rank or skill level but instead to learn
from your games improve
and just enjoy the ride after all if
your only goal is to get diamond and
keep it then your only fail-safe option
once you get there is to
never play again right
like at least until your rank decays
you're gonna lose some games that's
inevitable and ultimately
listen i'm here to tell you whatever you
are in your day-to-day life you are not
your mmr i'd
try to win a game of brood war and i'd
win and people go man you're good sean
and i'd be like yeah then i'd lose a
game of brood war and my brain would be
like you're not worthy of love
you are not really your your ladder rank
you're not really your starcraft skill
unless you're a pro gamer okay and if
you're a pro gamer it's your job and you
just have to queue on the ladder but
like if you don't play starcraft well
it doesn't mean anything about like your
intelligence or anything another factor
could be anxiety over social conflict
you could be afraid that you'll be
attacked either by your opponents or
your teammates depending on the game you
could make a mistake and be criticized
heavily for it this feels like a very
common factor for people because
ultimately we play games to have fun and
if that process of learning and
improving is made less fun by others
then it makes total sense that you'd
want to avoid that if possible this fear
is also constantly reinforced by our
surroundings i'm done
sick of this few streams diapers
you guys know you chat i quit streaming
and i quit this game but social pressure
goes even deeper than that and now the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about oh you thought i was only the guy
who knows what he's talking about when
it comes to tech i may have a computer
science degree but not only did i take
sports psychology and coaching classes
during my undergrad but i was also a
varsity athlete and team captain to boot
who's the nerd now
still me
fair point the pressure from teammates
opponents and even viewers in our ever
more connected gaming world is sort of
inescapable at this point you know they
get pressured and they start to think
more slowly and explicitly and that
actually leads to detriments in
performance because you have slower
reactions you're not thinking as
automatically you're double you know
you're questioning yourself basketball
players slapping hands after a missed
free throw or rainbow six pros fist
bumping after a lost round are both ways
for teams to try and dissipate some of
this pressure we've mostly been talking
about the mental impact but have you
ever been queuing up for a game or in
the middle of one and realized that
you're feeling the physical effects
things like an elevated heart rate maybe
some rapid breathing even colder sweaty
hands these symptoms are sometimes
called somatic anxiety and left
unchecked they can amplify the impact to
your performance even more your
physiological response to
anxiety can actually kind of act as a
feedback loop and
make your anxiety kind of worse right so
i would recommend like if you are having
those physiological signs if you are if
you do have climbing hands racing hard
etc to try and focus on um rectifying
those physiological responses before you
try to tackle diving into a range match
like have a have a cup of tea um sit
down try and kind of physically calm
yourself down before you jump in because
otherwise it'll just kind of feed into
itself physiological symptoms are a
pretty solid indicator that you're past
a level of stress that is going to help
motivate you to perform one of the core
elements in helping to build up your
tolerance for stress is your confidence
levels your perception of a stressor as
being out of your control is what begins
to overcharge your anxiety even if
something really is out of your control
confidence in yourself can help direct
your focus back to what you can control
this is why techniques like
visualization and that thing boomers are
always telling you about experience are
invaluable in helping competitors manage
those high stress moments and that was
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about so how can we eliminate or
at the very least just
manage these feelings well for one you
can ease yourself into the match sit
down take a deep breath put some music
on and just center yourself while you
run some deathmatch aimbots retakes
whatever that said we don't need to
completely eliminate these anxieties in
fact there's evidence to suggest that we
might not want to some athletes actually
cite anxiety as being a motivating
factor or a factor that helps them
perform in sports reframing thinking
like instead of perceiving um
failures as uh
failures perceiving failures instead as
an opportunity for growth and an
opportunity to learn about things the
next time you feel a stress response
remember it's not a bad thing it's
simple your body helping you rise to the
challenge so it's more about moderating
these anxieties and there are some
common strategies you can try that are
backed up by the research and i would
also suggest setting smaller goals to
kind of encourage that sense of
self-efficacy of achievement um so
rather than you know thinking i'm going
to win this match i'm going to top brag
think you know i'm going to
come
really well i'm going to calm my lineups
really well i'm going to comb my flashes
really well that's my goal for this
match so one of the ways that you can
improve
domain self-efficacy and again
self-efficacy is you know very strongly
associated with competitive state
anxiety one of the things that you can
do to improve your domain self-efficacy
is
experience mastery and experience
precarious learning madison points out
that it might actually be possible to
carry your feelings of mastery from a
game you are confident in or just are
confident watching
to the game that you are anxious about
playing so this isn't something that
i've had the opportunity to test but
what i suspect
is that if you are able to experience
mastery directly before queueing for a
ranked game or for a queueing for a
competition or a qualifier or something
like that is to
play another video game that you are
confident in that you feel good about
that you feel like you can perform
really well in there is some literature
to support that simply watching someone
else exhibit mastery like a pro player
on twitch can influence your own
self-efficacy positively listen
statistically
you're probably not a pro and the
reality is that
most of us don't have blinged out
liquipedia pages so it's sort of natural
that we would maybe be a little more
prone to beat ourselves up about our
performance and i think that's okay you
don't have to be amazing at the game to
reduce anxiety around
um playing around queueing up for ranked
but most importantly don't perceive
failure don't perceive mistakes as this
kind of
end-all horrible thing to happen if you
can reframe how you view these mistakes
as learning opportunities or
opportunities for innovation
opportunities for growth that will help
as well ultimately bladder anxiety isn't
really going anywhere because
competition isn't going anywhere the
hope is that with a new perspective and
having been able to frame maybe your own
anxiety in a new light
pressing that ranked button will just
come
a little bit easier
you can feel awful about yourself
anywhere
never wanted to ever wanted to
hate yourself
oh
facebook comments are like child's play
man let me introduce you to a fellow by
the name of yasuo